there is a reason that one of the
primary rules of the Internet is don't
read the comments so this is largely a
bit of a semi follow-up to the video I
did on toxic fandoms so I want to talk
in general about managing and curating
comment sections and pretty much got to
talk about my own I do I like to think
that anyone who has a channel that's
smaller than mine or has been doing this
for less time than I have maybe you can
take a few things away from this I'm not
claiming to be the best in the world
that at managing my comments but I mean
I'll give you my experiences my thoughts
on it and maybe you can do something
with it and for those of you who aren't
in that boat maybe it'll give you some
insight into how does I manage all of
this if you care so here we go I I do
still Monterey personally and curate my
comment section there is kind of a weird
nebulous zone for medium ish like on the
large side of small into medium ish size
YouTube channels when it comes to the
comment sections when you're when you're
a legitimately small youtube channel you
know 10,000 and less subscribers
curating your comment section not that
hard when you get to very big channels
you know your million subscribers and up
or really possibly even you're a hundred
thousand subscribers at up you can start
to get into areas where they may have
hired a third party they may have hired
somebody who basically serves as a
social media curator you know this maybe
it's someone who handles the Twitter
account
you know officially for the channel and
you know it's part of their job to
curate the comments once you get to a
certain size that kind of stuff gets
outsourced so it's in that middle ground
which I think I currently kind of fall
into where you oftentimes find a little
bit more of a wild west and I think I'm
kinda hit that point where I'm at a size
that it is less common for the creators
do continue to actively care
- comments cuz honestly guys a lot of
work to go through so let me talk about
and then what I say curate comments this
mainly has to do with what it is I
choose to remove because that's the big
part of curating comments now the first
thing that I'm gonna point out and that
anyone who is going to curate their
comments needs to keep in their mind
it's not a public forum it's your
channel you get to set the rules in the
ideal way in which people will interact
with you so I'll tell you the way that I
approach it that's not a gold standard
by any means you have whatever right
it's it's your platform you have
whatever right to handle comments
however you want this is how I approach
them so in terms of stuff that gets
deleted because that's mainly what I'm
gonna be talking about here the first
and foremost and this is something that
I call out specifically and I try to
warn people about his personal attacks
personal attacks against individuals
whether it's me whether it's another
commenter whether it is a creator for
the the thing that I'm talking about
when things become well first of all
there's certain pejorative language that
I'm sorry use that it's just gonna go
and no I'm not gonna repeat I'm not
gonna give you a list of words you you
know what are unacceptable words come on
people be adults but like when it
becomes a matter specifically you are an
idiot
you're stupid like when it when it gets
to that or that kind of sentiment where
you're not talking about ideas anymore
you're just belittling people or you
know big old effuse - to people and you
know that that's an easy call and
depending on how harsh and mean-spirited
that is honestly I meant to the block
you from the channel on first defense
yeah I don't have a three-strike system
here okay
so that but that's the easy call
personal attacks are honestly an easy
thing because that's just quality of
discourse that's just getting rid of
people who won't communicate in good
faith who will not talk to people as if
they deserve any respect and those kinds
of people
that's an easy call to chuck just Chuck
all that stuff out where things get a
little bit more if he is when you start
dealing with stuff and you have to sort
of gauge yourself am i deleting this
because it is it's actively hurting the
discourse that I want to go on or am i
deleting this just because I really
don't like what it says and again it's
your call on how you want to handle that
for myself I try to not delete things
because I don't agree with it I try to
have my deletions be about word use and
tone and basically the vibe I get off it
because you know I I'm a spirit of allah
guy not a letter of the law so if i read
a comment and it doesn't use a
pejorative term and technically doesn't
involve a direct attack but the entire
vibe i get off of it is confrontational
and trollee i'll there's a decent chance
I'll still get rid of it and look here's
the simple fact I'm doing this myself
and I'm human so there are some things
that are just factors that are gonna
vary from day to day I'm subject to mood
if I'm having a bad day then a comment
that on a better day might just have
squeaked by I'm like yeah fine I'll
approve it if I'm having a bad day I
just might delete it because I don't
want to deal with it again I'm human I'm
subject to to my mood and I try and I
try to be fair but I don't I'm not a
robot
alright so you know I don't claim to be
objective I actually that would be the
last thing I would claim to be on this I
try to be fair but I'm not a jekt
objective and it's not a court of law
and the part of the reason I'm doing
this is there was a couple of comments
that I ended up clearing out and
actually had to clear out twice and then
clear out somebody else who quoted the
comment and the person who quoted it
said I'm putting this here from this
commenter to see if you'll delete it
again basically I'm trying to shove it
in my face and and probably trying to
prove to themselves that I was trying to
stop
certain points of view but there was a
specific tone particularly in regards to
LGBTQ people and the use of phrase the
problem is you and people like you
directors specifically me that okay yeah
is that the most blatant direct attack
that's I've ever been thrown at me well
no but I can look at that time to go
yeah
don't want to deal with it and probably
the the time that I cross the most into
I'd suppose probably unfair cutting up a
comment is sometimes it is strictly for
my own mental well-being because
sometimes there are things that may not
specifically an outright break any other
rules I've just set out but sometimes
I'll see something that I I don't want
to engage with but I look at and I go I
I can't not respond to this but I also
don't trust myself to be able to respond
to it in a way that I won't be
embarrassed by later and if and that's
that becomes a matter of a personal
check and again I'm human and I try to
maintain a good tone and if I see
something in the comments that otherwise
maybe would skirt by but I think like I
see that there and I know it's there and
if I know it's there I'm gonna feel the
need to comment on it but if I do that's
gonna go south for either because it's
gonna be engaging with someone who I
know is trying to pull me out into a
fight which I don't want to do or it's
because I am personally frustrated
enough by a comment that I know I I
can't respond to it in a tone that is
respectful and sometimes I will leave it
but sometimes I will have to delete it
because although there's that part of me
that says you can't just have it there
and not say something I'm like and find
that it needs to not be there so that I
can know that for myself you know it's
nobody's perfect and I'm far from so
when I when there's something around
that is pulling the instincts and the
ideas and the things out of me that I
don't like that I that I want to have
better control of if I think that that
thing is going to pull that reaction out
of me a reaction that I'm not gonna be
proud of then sometimes I need to remove
the thing that's gonna provide that
that's pulling that reaction out of me
is that unfair yep
probably to be completely honest but
again it's my platform and I don't want
to wield that like I'm trying to be a
dictator
I do love my common section III honestly
I mean that curating it is exhausting
and sometimes depressing but I still
love my comment section I love the
interaction I don't respond directly to
comment as much as I used to because as
I keep getting bigger there's more and
more and more or more of them but I do
still look at them because I'm actively
curating these things and I see so many
things that I can look at that you know
make me go oh I hadn't thought of it
that way or just comments that I
appreciate or things that make me
positive go okay well he's pushing back
on this idea that I put forward maybe
it's worth my reexamining that idea or
they make suggestions that I may take on
directly or I may spawn an idea you know
my head I get inspired I get inspired by
you guys and by the comments section
heck this video was inspired by the
comment section of another video that
kind of proves the point I love my
comments section not all creators do and
sometimes that's a general nature of the
creator sometimes it has to do when they
talk about certain topics they'll
disable the comments because they don't
they know it's gonna be an utter just
minefield in the comment section and
they don't want to have to deal with it
and I think that's fair too but I try
really hard to not do that
because I don't
I don't want this channel to be an echo
chamber of just me I mean it is by and
large it's almost always me on the
camera don't want talking about stuff
but like I like that I say something
things go on in the comments section
sometimes what goes on the comments
section makes me think about something
and then I create something new through
what you guys have talked about and you
making me think about stuff and I it
feels more interactive because of that
and I've had to work really hard I mean
you know there will always be people
unhappy but if having one that a few
people say how much more respectful they
see my comments section is then in some
other places and I think a lot of that
has to do with the fact that I do
actively curate it I've never thrown up
my hands and gone to heck with it
everything's approved I don't want to
have to fish through these things again
no I have got a long long list of things
that cause comments to be flagged for
review not auto deleted but like a lot
of stuff will flag it for a review and
then I'll look at and go okay that's
fine that's fine that's not that's not
so like huh that video on toxic fandom I
like it's I have to guesstimate because
I didn't wait and do it all in one chunk
I did it in a couple of chunks over time
that it built up again all said and done
I probably had to you probably auto flag
then I had to review 200 some comments
and that's exhausting but it's also
worth it because I like to have an
environment where we can talk as long as
everyone's talking respectfully and
again I'm not perfect some days I might
delete something that I might otherwise
keep some days honestly I don't leave
things by accident like that does I it
doesn't happen much especially these
days I've done pretty good about it but
will you get well you have something in
the flag for review section the approved
button is right next to the delete
button and annoyingly you click
prove button it basically asks you are
you sure you click the delete button it
doesn't ask are you sure it just deletes
it you do it miss click and it's gone I
have actually done that a couple times
and that's that's embarrassing but that
doesn't happen a lot and I don't want to
throw that out make it sound like an
excuse by a large if I've removed a
comment I would say 98% of the time I
meant to probably about 85 to 90% of the
time I'm confident in that removal and
then there's about a nebulous you know
eight ish percent of the time where
maybe come in a bad mood and I'm just
not in the mood to deal with whatever
was in there and I just kill it rather
than deal with it again I try not to do
that but I'm a human being
it's that there you go those are my
general thoughts on on how I approach
comments sections what I do and don't
delete the thought process that I go
through and the justifications I have
for myself and I'm sure some people will
still you know accuse me of you know
deleting anything that doesn't agree
with me but I think if you look through
my comment sections especially when I
address more I cut I don't want to say
controversial I don't think these things
should be controversial but more loaded
topics it's not hard to find stuff that
doesn't agree with me there's a fair
chunk of it there
I don't delete everything that doesn't
agree with me I delete
pretty much everything that doesn't
agree with me and is a jerk about it
that's the number one rule of anything
that I get that I have control over and
I do get to have control over my own
comments section number one rule is
don't be a jerk and look and and I do I
do honestly think it's that simple you
know when you're being a jerk you can
rationalize it all you want you can go
will it they deserve it because they're
part of this group that I don't like or
they started it or you know I'm mad at
them because of this or it's okay
because of this like you have you can
have all the rationalizations you in the
world you want
in your heart of hearts you know when
you're being a jerk so just don't that
that's what I try and do don't always
succeed but that's what I try and do
that's what I ask other people to try
and do so there we go
comment sections okay fun well not bad
become a section on this one will be boy
this could just be a whole spiral down
whatever your thoughts are drop looming
down in the comments let's talk about it
and if you're not a jerk it'll actually
show up there's a whole bunch of links
down there and buttons and stuff there's
a link to my patreon if you feel like
supporting me that way if you don't
don't sweat it though other links you
can check out even if you don't want to
do those you know what doesn't really
matter because at the end of the day you
folks are the council and I just run the
meetings why I have the comments section
is why I curate it I do actually believe
that so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]